what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on uh later on in this
channel so what I want to do here is
kick off our whole throwback Thursday by
having a discussion on the death of
galatis now for those of you guys who
are new to my channel throwback Thursday
is quite literally when we just jump to
stories that took place before Secret
Wars before DC rebirth even before the
new52 and just look at Classic stories
from DC Marvel and various other
Publications Valiant image and so on and
so forth but the idea is to show you
guys there are still some great stories
out there not only that there are some
stories that came before Secret Wars and
and DC rebirth that I absolutely loved
and so you know I really don't want to
let these stories be passed by I don't
want to let those stories go without
being told and so the idea here is to
basically bring you these stories now
the death of galatis is really more of
uh setting the stage for future things
and what I mean here is in the 1990s
we've talked about this before on my
channel in the 1990s things were in a
state of flux you know for for the comic
book industry DC was a little better off
than Marvel was and the reason why is
while both companies were suffering
while sales for both companies were at
their lowest simply because of the big
comic bus because people stopped buying
Comics after they came to realize that
you know the death of Superman wasn't
going to be worth $20,000 in 20 years
the sales were at an all-time low but
Warner Brothers had purchased DC Comics
and so DC had corporate backing so even
if they went to their lowest there would
always be money that would be dumbed
into them to make sure the characters
like Superman and Batman and Wonder
Woman you know the Justice League that
they all stayed around with Marvel
Comics it wasn't that way Marvel Comics
was quite literally flying by the seat
of their pants you know the idea was
they' just got to crank out stories as
best they can and so Galactus the devour
brings us this it brings us an attempt
to both boost the sales of Marvel Comics
even if it's only by virtue of this one
story as well as set the stage for a
complete revitalization of the Fantastic
4 because during this time the Fantastic
4 just weren't selling those of you guys
who saw my history or my my videos on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic 4 uh that
run and probably Mark Wade's run before
that were really the only two instances
within the last maybe 15 years that the
Fantastic 4 actually had good runs prior
to those two story arcs there really
wasn't a whole lot going on the
Fantastic 4 were really slipping in
popularity so as we jump into this what
we do is we have Louise Simonson who's
writing this basically kind of
refreshing us on on the Silver Surfer
now there are some aspects that tie into
this for example there was a point at
which uh silver surf's home planet of
Zen La was restored by Galactus but then
ended up dissolving Silver Surfer had
been imprisoned on Earth as we knew when
he first showed up when he turned
against Galactus after a while he was
allowed to escape his Exile but the
problem with this is that along the
Journey of his character's you know
creation along the path of his
publication history as he was written by
different writers leading up to this
point the Silver Surfer had basically
just lost what it was that made him uh
made him human or at least as close to
human as he could get that made him
unique and so the Silver Surfer in this
segment of his publication history and
this part of his life is back on Earth
in an attempt to kind of regain his
humanity and his his ability to do this
was brought on by a woman named Alicia
Masters now a lot of you guys know
Alicia Masters as the girlfriend of Ben
Grim they had a strong relationship and
it was really a way to ground Ben Grim's
character and to make him appear more
human than he actually was the problem
with this was that a Silver Surfer was
struggling you know the Ben Grim would
always do well because he was always
with the Fantastic for you know coming
out of the original Secret Wars event
when he had basically left Alicia
Masters and so on and so forth when he
was replaced with She-Hulk and various
other people to be the strong guy so to
speak for the Fantastic Four Marvel
began to shift Alicia Masters away from
being the girlfriend of Ben Grim to
being the girlfriend of Silver Surfer
and she allowed him to regain his
Humanity not only that Alicia Masters
experienced some expansions to her own
character in the sense that yes she
remained blind there was a point whereby
Silver Surfer restored her sight but
that was temporary um but she also has
like a nanotech armor that allows her to
you know go into the depths of space and
to follow Silver Surfer alongside his
journeys and so so this part of the
story just kind of gives us that it just
tells us Silver Surfer is still
operating as a hero on Earth he's doing
what he can you know just kind of uh
operating you know alone but also
working alongside the Avengers The
Fantastic 4 and so on but it also shows
us that there are some issues that go on
between himself and Ben Grim that Ben
Grim's still not really happy about the
fact that Alicia Masters is with Silver
Surfer as opposed to being with him but
the fact remains here that the the plot
as it takes place in this part of the
story is pretty small Tom in the sense
that meman has basically shown up with
his H mids and they have their own
little campaign so on and so forth not
the biggest thing it's just kind of
giving us a refresher the real aspect of
uh of Galactus or I guess the real part
of the story that begins moving into the
territory of the death of Galactus is
when Galactus himself arrives on earth
now the arrival of Galactus at Earth is
a huge thing and the reason why is
because when when he originally
encountered the Fantastic 4 there were a
couple instances when he returned but on
the whole Johnny Storm had secured the
ultimate nullifier which is capable of
wiping out whatever it is that is
pointed at and Reed Richards had used it
on Galactus basically saying if you ever
come back here trying to consume the
Earth you will be destroyed we will wipe
you out and so Galactus had always sort
of stayed away but the question that
existed is what would have happened if
Galactus had died and that's the Crux
behind the story it tells us what
happens or at the very least it lays the
groundwork for telling us what happens
later on which I'll reveal at the end of
the story but the fact remains that with
Galactus showing up uh back at Earth
again Silver Surfer immediately becomes
aware of his presence just because
there's kind of a bond there you know
when it comes to Galactus and his
Heralds his Heralds or even former
Heralds always know of where he's
located at at anyone particular time
this also comes with the power Cosmic
which allows his Heralds to have you
know Cosmic awareness which is to say to
know everything that's going on in the
universe at that particular point in
time what we also learn is that Galactus
does not come alone the Galactus has his
own Herald named red shift now red shift
is going to be very very fast in the
story that is to say he's not going to
last long because of the fact that
Silver Surfer still resides on Earth
Galactus has basically you know shown up
here but also realizes that the Silver
Surfer will oppose him and so under the
uh I guess under the orders of Galactus
red shift attacks silver Surfer and
confines both the surfer and Alicia
Masters into a black hole basically
laying the landscape for for Galactus to
um to begin consuming Earth the problem
with this is that uh you know red shift
has been confined to this black hole uh
in the same way that that Silver Surfer
and Alicia Masters have but in addition
to this we also learn what's going on
with galatis himself now initially
silver surver was able to hold his own
against red shift and in fact he
actually ends up killing red shift the
problem with this is that with the two
of them being stuck inside of a black
hole and presumably being unable to
escape because of the fact that it is a
Silver Surfer because of the fact that
he's able to use all different forms of
the power Cosmic Louis Simonson really
stretches the limits of crul here and
basically has the Silver Surfer shrink
himself down to the point where he's
able to access the microverse which is a
universe within our main Universe on an
extremely microscopic level for those of
you guys who saw the Ant-Man movie when
uh Scott Lang was shrinking down uh
smaller and smaller he was reaching the
point whereby he would actually access
the microverse it's that small and it
has its own inhabitants and all that
kind of good stuff the silver server
shrinks down down to the size of the
microverse basically like moves through
the particles of the black hole and then
is able to uh to escape back in a normal
space like I said it's really stretching
the limits of crul here but the fact
remains that it allows the Silver Surfer
to uh to reemerge the problem with this
is that when he comes back to the planet
Earth the arrival of Galactus has drawn
the attention of the Fantastic 4 The
Avengers all the Earth superheroes and
it's really just panic mode it's oh my
God Galactus is here he's going to
consume the world we've got to do
something now because of the fact that
Silver Surfer is so close to galatis the
first thing does ask why are you doing
this and what we find out is because
Silver Surfer was so important for the
survival of Galactus meaning that Silver
Surfer traveled around the cosmos took
Galactus to planets that were uh that
that lacked sentient life but had the
kind of uh kind of elements necessary
for Galactus to consume and keep himself
alive when Silver Surfer had vacated
none of the Heralds were able to really
hold up to the Legacy that he created
they weren't really able to save the or
serve the same function and so the
result is that over the years that
Silver Surfer has been gone galac cus
has been been growing continually hungry
he's he's basically become ravenous and
that's what's happening here instead of
going around and consuming planets that
uh that lack sentient life but have the
kind of things he needs to survive
instead he's eating whatever he can find
which means consuming sentient life
consuming the energies of people even if
it's necessary and so for the most part
Louis Simonson gives us what we would
expect to see which is you know the
various superheroes doing what they can
to face off against them now you do see
superheroes here like like Thor you do
see superheroes like Scarlet Witch one
of the things that I want to point out
here especially with Scarlet Witch
herself is those of you guys who are
looking at this comic now but you may
have you know picked up Marvel comics
with Secret Wars or you may have picked
up with you know Avengers disassembled
or House of M the Scarlet Witch that you
know of is a wildly powerful character
she's really a multiversal threat when
she you know stripped uh 98% of the
mutant population of their powers during
the house of Iman that was a multiversal
effect she affected all the mutants in
every reality it wasn't just the main
Earth 616 continuity I'm pretty sure
that was established by Beast or Cyclops
during the uh during the post I think it
was decimation but the fact remains here
that this version of scarlet which as
you see her now uh is not this powerful
she is powerful but she's really more
confined to creating hex's and
manipulating magic she's not altering
reality at this point in her life and so
because of this you know the superheroes
Wonderman the Fantastic 4 uh you know
they're really not able to do anything
to hold off against Galactus and so the
Silver Surfer is kind of at he's he's at
a bad position here once he actually
goes to see Galactus himself you know I
guess the second time he also begins to
realize that galac is continually
growing more sickly at a much faster
rate the result here is a Silver Surfer
is basically in a quagmire and he comes
to the realization that because his
absence sent Galactus down this path
he's going to have to return to Galactus
and become his Herald once again and
that's exactly what Silver Surfer does
he effectively leaves everything behind
and he begins traveling the cosmos in
order to find worlds for galatis now
this is the caveat under normal
circumstances the Silver Surfer could
just travel across the cosmos for weeks
or months at a time trying to find a
suitable Planet he does not have that
kind of time frame here because Galactus
is so ravenous because Galactus is
starving because he's desperate and will
do whatever he needs to do in order to
consume planets and consume life in
order to to bolster his own energies
silver surfer's area of searching is
actually pretty limited here he really
has to find a planet that he can that
the galais can consume that is not
filled with sentient life in a very
short amount of time now while this is
happening the Fantastic Four are really
focusing on a way to defeat galatis and
this is also what's kind of interesting
here is because we'll actually see them
go about their own life they'll actually
go about you know doing regular things
once the threat of galatis uh seems to
have verified as being gone but as
Silver Surfer is going through his
journeys he eventually stumbles across a
planet called verin and runs into a
character named mantis now mantis is a
mixed bag and mantis really represents
the times when Marvel just goes off the
rails and that that happens for those of
you guys who who are not uh really
experienced with Marvel Comics there are
stories when they just they just lose it
they just lose their ever loving mind it
all just goes It goes to pot and no one
really knows why but the idea idea
behind mantis was that she was an
experiment by Marvel Comics to see if
they could replace the former love
interest of Silver Surfer shalal with a
new love interest whether or not fans
would be receptive to that now fans were
kind of receptive but at the same time
Silver Surfer had such a long running
history that fans wanted his history to
remain intact and much like you know the
initial response to Mary Jane Watson
taking the place of gwy Stacy after she
died fans did not want to see a
character take the place of shalal
because the death of shalal was really
the the ongoing theme behind Silver
Surfer it was the ongoing theme of why
he felt life to be so valuable and so
because of this uh there was a point at
which uh you know both shalal and mantis
were taken prisoner by the Elders of the
universe and they were caught in an
explosion shalal survived and mantis was
presumed dead the problem with this was
that Marvel also found that there was
somewhat of an audience here and so what
they did is they basically had mantis's
Consciousness spread all across the
universe and silver surer would just run
into her at different points during his
publication history and different
versions of her would be depicted
different ways which allowed Marvel to
experiment on which version fans liked
and then keep that version going in the
comics and so at this particular point
this is where you know Silver Surfer
runs upon a version of herself uh who
isn't really uh villainous or she's not
really evil she's really more of a
person that enjoys life and understands
the value of life but she's also
familiar with the history of Silver
Surfer and when the point came when she
you know when she had died when her
Consciousness was spread across the
universe the Silver Surfer had already
vacated his position as a Herald of
Galactus and so when she stumbles into
him and she finds he's a Herald of
Galactus yet again the question is why
are you here the most logical answer
being I'm trying to find a planet that
galatis can consume and so what they end
up doing is both Silver Surfer and
mantis begin traveling around together
trying to find other planets that
Galactus can consume now this is
actually going to be a huge Act of
betrayal on behalf of Silver Surfer and
what I mean is that when they find a
planet that does not that has sentient
life but it's not intelligent sentient
life which means that it has dinosaurs
and primitive life and so on and so
forth that wouldn't recognize that their
own Doom is coming when they go back to
G galus and they tell him they found a
planet Galactus lashes out and the
reason he lashes out is because he knows
that Silver Surfer had traveled to Veron
he knows that the planet that mantis was
already on is a planet that could easily
sustain him instead Silver Surfer wants
Galactus to travel farther than he needs
to to find a Planet worth consuming and
so this really creates an interesting
dichotomy between the two because Silver
Surfer believes he's operating on behalf
of Galactus and Galactus was mostly uh
under the mindset of trusting wherever
it was the Silver Surfer would send him
but because he's so ravenous and because
he's so desperate he takes a very
dictatorial approach and says that the
Silver Surfer will take him where where
Galactus wants to be taken the Silver
Surfer will not take Galactus where the
Silver Surfer thinks Galactus should go
and so again the idea here is that he
basically uh it seems that Galactus is
more or less gone insane that he's
basically lost his mind and so the idea
is that Galactus is effectively going to
consume verin which he does he consumes
the entirety of verin and mantis dies in
the process now again galus takes a very
dark approach where he tells the Silver
Surfer yes I'm cosing you all the things
that you like but I don't care you're my
Herald take me to a planet that I can
consume and so because of the fact that
Galactus seems to have lost his mind in
its entirety Silver Surfer comes up with
a plan he basically comes to the
conclusion that Galactus is beyond the
point of return that there's really no
retribution here there's no way to send
Galactus back to being his normal self
and so he comes up with the idea that
the Shar can destroy galatis now the
reason why Silver Surfer came up with
this plan is in Marvel Comics there was
a story called operation Galactic storm
and this really dealt with the cre had
dealt with the fact that their race was
frozen in time I've got a video on that
about the history of the cre that you're
welcome to check out in the description
if you guys want to learn more about
them but the fact remains that operation
Galactic storm was a uh was really a
ruse it was a campaign created by the
cre supreme ruler I guess the Supreme
intelligence in order to jump start
their racist Evolution and it initiated
a war with the shiar knowing the shar's
weapons of extreme destruction would
wipe out a majority of the uh of the C's
race and then Force the cre to basically
jump start in order for them to evolve
in order to survive and so because of
this Silver Surfer knows that the uh the
Shi Empire have a weapon capable of
totally obliterating Galactus or at
least it seems they have a weapon
capable of of obliterating Galactus and
so when Silver Surfer arrives to uh to
meet with the Shi Empire they
immediately believe that he's a Herald
of Galactus now this is done for a
couple reasons and in fact Louis
Simonson is not wildly specific here she
doesn't really need to be but she's not
really specific here we don't know if
the sh Empire was watching the events on
Earth and realize that Silver Surfer was
now a Herald of Galactus or if they
didn't know that Silver Surfer had
abandoned Galactus and has returned to
him they don't really know that all they
know is that the Silver Surfer means the
coming of galatis and so their idea is
to defeat the Silver Surfer interrogate
him for information and then turn around
and see what they can do the issue is
that the arrival of the Silver Surfer
again meeting with the cre beforehand
informing them of what was going on also
meeting with the star Jammers who are
kind of like Renegades uh within the the
Marvel Universe he's basically kind of
concocted a plan so his goal is to come
to the shiar Empire tell them what's
going on now when he is initially taken
prisoner once he awakens he basically
says Galactus is absolutely lost his
mind galatis is just traveling around
the cosmos now consuming you know
planets that are rich with sentient life
is something that I've always tried to
avoid you know but there's really no
stopping him the only thing that we can
do is use the shiar super weapon to
destroy him in addition to this Silver
Surfer had also contacted the uh the
Fantastic 4 The Avengers and so this is
really kind of like a Marvel Universe
versus Galactus kind of scenario which
would make a really good title for this
video but the fact remains that that
it's really a you know Galactus versus
the Marvel Universe situation it's
everyone's attempt to stop Galactus now
something else to also take note of here
is that the shiar are again one of the
most advanced Societies in the universe
because of this they're well aware of a
lot of things that go on more
specifically with the Endeavors of
galatis now because of the fact that
Reed Richards had fended off against
Galactus because he had sent Galactus
running during their first encounter
when he use the ultimate nullifier even
if the shiar Empire doesn't really like
Reed Richards per se especially after
the trial of Reed Richard's storyline
they also recognize that Reed Richards
is quite possibly the smartest man in
the entirety of the universe Dr Doom
shares this position with him which is
why I say quite possibly because it kind
of goes back and forth between the two
but the fact remains that when it comes
to the idea of Galactus Reed witchers is
kind of the foremost authority on this
and so because of the fact that Reed
witchers is here the question the shiar
Empire has is if our super weapon
doesn't work do you have a device that
can galatis and Reed Richard says I may
not have one here right now but we can
make one and so this is basically again
an all Hands-On deck it's the Avengers
doing what they can it's the the shiar
Empire you know working alongside the
cre and the Scrolls it's really kind of
a coming together that we' never really
seen before in the Marvel Universe and
so the result here is that once galatis
or at least once they seem to be
prepared they all basically start
launching an attack against Galactus in
an attempt to destroy him the issue is
that when the ship crash lands uh
Galactus is actually not there instead
Galactus had basically duped them not
only that because of the fact that
Galactus had realized that the entirety
of the Marvel Universe was moving
against him Galactus had feasted on on
countless worlds for the purpose of
taking out all those who would oppose
him again this basically just highlights
how insane Galactus is gone and so when
he arrives it's the totality of
galactus's power against all these
superheroes but at the same time we all
they also have different modifications
they have enhancements all different
kinds of technology that have been
brought together by this vast inner
working of races in to defeat him now
while Silver Surfer does try to reason
with Galactus one more time this again
also turns out to be a ruse Galactus
looks at Silver Surfer as a traitor and
the fact that Silver Surfer had
basically taken the forces of the
universe and moved them against galatis
but Silver Surfer says look you you have
to stop this yet you know you have to
bring this to an end if you stop then
everything will be fine but if you keep
going you're going to be destroyed and
while Galactus IGN noys this in the end
the super weapon is launched he's
embroiled in really more energy than he
seems to be able to uh to take on the
energy is dispersed in its entirety and
Galactus seems to be completely defeated
the issue with this is that Galactus
says as he's dying and as his energy
begins to emerge that Galactus was not
the threat here that yes Galactus was
going insane yes he was dangerous but he
wasn't simply just running around
consuming planets to keep himself alive
that he was the gatekeeper but on the
other side of this gate now that this
now that he's gone and there's no
gatekeeper to keep guard here on the
other side of this gate is a threat far
worse than Galactus himself for those
you guys who are very familiar with
Marvel Comics you know this threat
actually comes in the creation or the
reintroduction to the Marvel Universe of
a multiversal guy named
abraxis but with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end I
really hope you guys enjoy this it was
actually a really really cool set of
events to see the entirety of the Marvel
Universe moving towards galatis trying
to defeat him now the actual
introduction of abraxis takes place in
the Fantastic Four stories and this is
why it's really really cool is because
it involves the totality of Franklin
Richard's
Powers doesn't it always doesn't it
always involve Franklin Richards just
fixing everything but the fact remains
that if you guys are interested in
seeing something like that uh make sure
you guys drop a like make sure you hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core and leave a comment down below say
yes Rob I really want to see a story
where Franklin Richards resurrects
Galactus from the dead I really want to
see that happen I really want to see a
story where a guy named abis starts
going through the Multiverse and killing
off every version of galatis in the
Multiverse I want to see that
happened anyway uh let me know what you
guys think and uh yeah I will catch you
all later
[Music]
peace